جوله وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه في المنطقه
لم تخمد الاضطراب الامنيه والسياسيه في
اسرائيل الممتده منذ عمليه الحي
الاستيطانيه يعقوب في القدس ومتلاها في
سلوان وهذه الارتدادات تعكسها وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه بوضوح فقد وصلت الى
مستوى استعاده ما جرى عام 37
ونهايه الدوله التي عرفتها حاولت ان اقارن
بين قلق اليوم على الدوله وبين قلق عام 73
اكتشفت انني كنت اقل قلقا ذلك
الشرطه الاسرائيليه تقول انها ابقت قواتها
في حاله انذار قصوه وتؤكد تلقيها معلومات
تنظر بوقوع عشرات الهجمات يوميا وخشيتها
من تكرار ما جرى خلال عمليه سيف القدس او
ما تسميها اسرائيل حامل اسوار
الاول بدات شرطه اسرائيل
من العمليات الاخيره
في غزه كما تعلم يمكن لمشير المصري ان
يوزع حلوى ولكن الغريب اطلاق المفرقعات
الناريه ورفع اعلام حماس في مخيم اللاجئين
في شعفاط
وبين التحليل وكواليس السياسه في الاعلام
الاسرائيلي يستمر التصعيد الاسرائيلي قتلا
واعتقالا وهدما في القدس ومناطق الضفه